hi and welcome to the second program of
Sara's music I'm Sara Willis and it's
summer in Berlin where everything moves
outdoors including classical music today
I'm at the vault bruna translation
forest stage in Berlin where over 22
thousand Berliners bring their picnics
to enjoy concerts and other events in
the open air a couple of weeks ago the
Rolling Stones played here and tonight
I'm playing here with my orchestra the
Berlin Philharmonic but my seat in the
horn section is much further back than
where Mick Jagger was standing our
conductor today at the vault Pune and
also my guest on today's program is a
superstar in the classical music world
the venezuelan conductor Gustavo Dudamel
so this is the view from my seat in the
horn section it's an amazing view and
it's even more impressive in a minute
when the audience starts coming I have
something here I want to show you
it's my musicians open-air concert
survival kit first of all I need my horn
of course and almost as important
mosquito spray because under these
really strong lights it attracts big
bugs and the last thing we want is a
mosquito to land on us while we're
playing a really hard solo clothes pegs
to hold music down when it's windy a
warm black jumper because when the Sun
Goes Down it can be really chilly
onstage sunglasses for when the sun's
shining in your face and very important
last but not least an umbrella because
you never know open-air concerts can be
total wash outs like at the Berlin
Philharmonic vault Bruna concert in 2012
where everyone and everything got soaked
but our audience stay put and sangra
Lena look even more energetically than
usual
but we are so lucky today look the
weather is perfect for an open-air
concert and I'm gonna go and talk to
some of the picnickers to see just what
they are going to be eating during the
concert Oh is 84 fees yeah well here at
man the guns a bank first se
oh yeah this is good yeah you don't live
in Berlin you live in Japan ah
and you came extra for the vodka concert
yes so we fantastic great you like
concerts in the open air
yeah it's very good okay check this week
members do you do you I do here okay oil
oh yeah
now go dance net loss photography I am
amazing also a senior compromised at
home Dos Equis geek we have an investor
clucks yeah I can survive you know yeah
really cancer
yeah over the past years the number of
open-air classical music festivals in
Germany has risen remarkably despite
having to occasionally battle the
elements I think that listening to a
concert in the open air is a wonderful
change to sitting in the concert hall I
love my job even after all this filming
and looking very important with a camera
team with me I still have to show my
backstage pass this is my colleague
Jonathan Kelly he's principal oboe in
the Berlin Philharmonic and he is not
playing tonight Jonathan you look like
I'm playing so what are you going to do
instead I have my picnic I have my
plastic bottle in here yeah chilled
white wine looks like something else and
then drinks for the kids we've got
sandwiches you've got quiche homemade
quiche we're gonna have a sell to
celebrate and a picnic you know great
having fries yeah
in every program I'd like to share with
you some of my favorites and today
because we're in the open air I'd like
to share some of my favorite open-air
concerts
three of the most famous singers in the
world Anna Netrebko
Placido Domingo and Rolando villas on
sang here at the Val FINA together in
2006 this concert has become a classic
and this is what I call a grand finale
Gustavo Dudamel my guest on today's
program conducted this performance of
Giuseppe Verdi's Requiem at the famous
Hollywood Bowl in 2013
Gustavo Dudamel stellar career began in
the Venezuelan music education program
el sistema he has been the chief
conductor of the Los Angeles
Philharmonic since 2009
and now today's guest Rustavi be
tomorrow so
maestro Gustavo Dudamel this is what
backstage looks like at an open-air
concert it's not so glamorous is what
you're usually used to well yes he's
glamorous for it to be an open-air no in
the middle of the forest is wonderful
you know I was thinking when you turn
your back on 22,000 people when you're
conducting the music you sometimes
forget that they're there and then
you're really surprised at the end no I
think no I think I then you always feel
the energy coming from that amount of
people that is unique you know the
energy is going there but also it's
coming from from here from them I feel
it's amazing at the Philharmonia you
know it doesn't matter where you sit
here there's always where you stand you
have arrived but I heard a story you
also do lots of open-air concerts in the
Hollywood Bowl with your orchestra you
have Los Angeles for money and a friend
of mine in New York astir told me during
the quiet moments in the Hollywood Bowl
they hear the bottles rolling down this
melon I know a second that is the good
thing is they I think at them at the pub
unit that you know you are not allowed
to bring glasses and that is why you
know it's a little bit more quiet quiet
but works different for us in Los
Angeles they are people that you know
they have been for 40 years 50 years
supporters of the orchestra they have a
special place so then we have waiters we
have everything so yes no we have the
service of you can go is it's like you
have you can have a dinner a really
elegant dinner kind of open-air but
absolutely it's really incredible isn't
it how quietly 22,000 people can sit and
listen this is the thing the loudest
person or the loudest thing is usually
the bird a bird is likely I think in
this case we will have some sounds with
them
with the fluids and they in the pickle
of fluid that they will call the tension
of the day of the birth I'm sure of that
another thing that bothers us musicians
sometimes is mosquitoes and in the dress
rehearsal yesterday I saw big mosquito
fly past you and you just did that with
your hand it's I thought you were gonna
bring in the bases but I'm oh you were
doing with all these was a big spider
fly it was the kind of a spider or
something a an insect that was really
huge then I was like your conductor we
have to play in these things land it's
slightly choreographically perfect for
one two three four my last question for
you open air in Venezuela what do you do
you do any open air constant we you know
that in our in our Center Social Action
Center for music though that we have in
Venezuela we have an open-air stage and
we have concerts there for as 20,000
people I think it's beautiful because
sometimes we cannot expect expect for
people to come to you you know for the
community to come do we have to go you
know go and bring our music to the vibe
you know political that's all for Sara's
music today thank you for joining us
I've got to go and play the concert I
have my horn I have my mosquito spray
hope you enjoy the music and see you
next time
Virginia this is not BC is the most
difficult instrument I absolutely agree